guys today I'm going to show you how to
start your Honda CRV if you've got a
dead key fob first thing we got to do if
you're locked out is get in so what we
want to do
it's right here on the back of your key
fob you got a little a little switch
push the little switch over
pull the key right out
put the key in your slot turn it
you're in your car now let's get in and
start it
okay when I do these demonstrations I
take the battery out just to show
everybody that this is a dead key fob to
start this car first thing you got to do
and I'm going to show you it won't start
so I'm going to push the button I'm
gonna put my foot on the brake I push
the button nothing happens
so to start it what you got to do is put
your foot on the brake then take the
corner of this key fob and push it to
the power button
[Music]
and there you go
your car is started
dead key fob started car well guys first
thing don't forget to put your hide a
key back in its place
hey if you're stranded and this got you
going hey please leave me a comment and
let me know hey if this helped you out
please give me a thumbs up subscribe to
my channel until next time I will catch
you later
[Music]